plus besoin de réservation c'est parti
pour une heure et demie de magie la
visite commence par le temple des
prestiges pour accueillir à nouveau du
public
ils ne proposent plus d'illusions
tactiles elles sont uniquement
visualiser la plus tranchante
donc en général je prends les votes tu
vas salle du bas une chose à voir
sympathique pour les enfants je pense
qu'à plein de telle merveille
mon très bonnes découvertes super ça les
intéresse et nous aussi pas mal
d'illusions et
j'aime bien autre nouveauté cette année
le salon magique us des tours de magie
ils sont proposés pour petits et grands
oui exactement de la mer l'eau enfin ça
fait un moment qu'on envoie mais ça
m'impressionne toujours autant c'est un
super spectacle j'étais content de
monter sur scène
ca c'est la première fois pour le
magicien aussi cet été 2021 est synonyme
de retour à la normale
pour nous c'est un vrai plaisir de déjà
de prendre le spectacle de pouvoir
interagir à nouveau avec les spectateurs
et de revenir finalement un spectacle
quasi quasi normal puisque on peut
reprendre un peu tous nos tours de magie
classique vraiment jouer avec les riffs
et spectateurs avec cent mille visiteurs
par an le musée reste l'un des plus
visités de la région comme si la magie
continue ai dit ok